bon
[Musique]
et
l'agriculture urbaine l'hiver on a fait
des risques de terre on a fait du cas
obliger à couleurs la bette à carde des
betteraves rouges jaunes de l'aneth
l'accord liant deux sortes de persil et
tous ont été vendus ici en bas tout sur
le toit de cette épicerie de ville saint
laurent monsieur du chemin visite son
jardin de 2500 m² je lis sous la neige
on espérait nogent bord on cultive sur
le toit puis la livraison mais ces 44
marche plus tard on reçoit la
marchandise à bord ont fait la mise en
marché une trentaine de variétés de
légumes et de fruits
oui les réductions d'îlots de chaleur ça
c'est bien pour ça mais aussi le tout le
transport qui se fait pour la ferme
jusqu'ici ou la californie ou la floride
jusqu'ici à ciel ouvert comme ça c'est
un peu comme dans les régions maréchal
des grandes régions à richard du québec
l'olivaie sol et des leaders soudanais
je pense qu'on est des pionniers puis on
aimerait faire imiter un avec des gens
fassent pareil que même mieux alors moi
je pense qu'il va en avoir d'autres pays
au québec au canada
montréal
nous voici dans les serres de l'uqam
pour éric duchemin du laboratoire sur
l'agriculture urbaine
il est important de réfléchir à notre
façon de consommer localement l'hiver
l'idée c'est vraiment de zéro on peut
produire à montréal on va pas nourrir
l'ensemble population que c'est avec
cette production l'homme on va nourrir
une partie mais surtout roma en place
des éléments de l'écosystème on voit
beaucoup de fonctions la great urbaine
et l'hiver bat au début on faisait ses
qualités ce qu'elle était et en ville il
ya vraiment un peu capacité de récupérer
la chaleur des bâtiments en mettant des
serres ayant quand même des projets à
l'intérieur donc soit sur des toits dans
des serres ou encore eu des producteurs
qui font du qu'on appelle des lindor
donc dû quelque part de la production
intérieure
nous sommes dans le nouveau supermarché
avril à laval
ici on cultive une trentaine de variétés
de pouce de l'étude d'herbe de
betteraves dans cette ferme verticale un
mur de 12 mètres de haut avec des
plateaux pour maximiser l'espace sous
ses lumières colorées pousse les
aliments qui se retrouveront au bistrot
en bas ou dans l'épicerie ça donne
vraiment un bon coup d'oeil mais qu'est
ce que la dass et comme notre jardin
urbain qui vous voyez tous nos légumes
feuilles et nos micros poste ont fait
pousser là se placer comme dans une
serre mais on le fait aussi pour
l'aspect environnement
c'est une grosse réduction de gaz à
effet serre on est on les cultive sur
place donc il faut être transparent rien
c'est surtout pour compléter un peu
l'expérience client qu'à convient
magasin avoir des micropuces qui pousse
chez nous que les clients voient pousser
qui sont capables d'y et ben la
traçabilité que ça part de là ça descend
directement au comptoir sa conquête
notre expérience avec ça c'est vraiment
la tendance les gens
l'allemande il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
gens qui se tourne vers l'alimentation
crudivore d'héberger des v guindé des
végétaliens donc oui c'est de plus en
plus recherchée ce type d'aliment où il
faut donner un côté marketing et c'est
tellement beau un peu poignet sauf que
quand qu'on mange
c'est plus marketing la fraîcheur à
l'explosion bouche c'est incroyable
c'est clair qu'elle espère marketing
d'intérêt on veut faire venir les gens
ça reste un supermarché à ça reste une
entreprise mais en même temps c'est des
pionniers actuellement ça coûte
excessivement cher c'est des pionniers à
beaucoup de ses erreurs parce que
beaucoup de choses qu'on connaît pas sur
toutes les fermes intérieur les lumières
artificielles ont qui est plein
d'éléments seulement sont vraiment
développement
[Musique]
bonjour martin bonjour c'est ici dans
quel psy que ça se passe effectivement
oui dans quelle agriculture dans
l'église lieu de l'agriculture je vais
te voir ça et on va les voir ça alors je
vous emmène à la sacristie c'est là
qu'on a nos prototypes d'installation
l'eau pour la production
attention la lumière c'est ici dans
cette église de saint pacôme que martin
braud développe la technologie et
l'équipement de cette agriculture
urbaine qui est à l'origine des
installations au supermarché avril cette
ferme verticale occupera et show fera
éventuellement toute l'église pour
produire près de 120 mille kilos
d'aliments
l'idée était aussi de s'approcher de l'
expertise en agriculture déjà présente
dans la région
la réflexion qu'on a eu pour développer
des technologies c'est vraiment de
trouver une solution pour les enjeux
climatiques
l'idée de départ et les venues peut-être
sur les réflexions des souveraineté
alimentaire dans le nord mais ça s'est
propagé en modèle d'affaires dans le
fond pour se créer notre entreprise les
équipements permettent de faire en sorte
que ce soit la meilleure journée de
l'année pour les plantes à chaque jour
de l'année
la qualité de la lumière c'est pas mal
le secret de la sauce là dedans on
arrive à sculpter certain goût certaines
caractéristiques des plans
de manière assez contrôlé avec
l'éclairage pour l'instant ce sont des
tests exploratoires
les récoltes sont distribués à moisson
kamouraska éventuellement tout sera
commercialisée mais pour le consommateur
ce genre d'agriculture coûte cher comme
toute la production biologique qui a un
coût supplémentaire
la grue sur ben a souvent ce même coup
supplémentaire là nous avons 20 30% plus
cher que le prix moyen des légumes
depuis qu'on mène au micro pousse en
avant dans nos supermarchés en
augmentation de 20 à 25 % juste dans
cette catégorie 2
de légumes on parle beaucoup des saines
habitudes de vie saines habitudes
alimentaires la grippe sur ben
participation parce que enfin prendre
conscience aux gens que produire des
aliments c'est pas si simple
donc c'est tout une compréhension
l'éducation qui se fait grâce à ses
projets de la glisse urbaine sans
oublier que ces méthodes peuvent aussi
réduire le gaspillage alimentaire
voilà un rayon fruits et légumes normale
entre chez nous le sap r 3 4 % de pertes
tandis que les produits frais du toit
c'est pratiquement 0% peur on va toutes
les récoltes ont déjà presque rien qui a
promis une liste des pertes en faisant
ce pour essayer car je n'ai rien qui
veut à la belle eau chaude finalement ça
n'arrive pas s'il faut se projeter dans
l'avenir pour voir tevez passé est-ce
que savoir répondre c'est des besoins
des personnes vulnérables
pour l'instant on répond plutôt à des
besoins de personnes qui ont de l'argent
qui veulent avoir des aliments de
qualité donc il tenait sa provenance les
fermes urbaines met maintenant sont
vraiment pour les personnes un peu plus
aisés mais peut-être que ça amener des
solutions pour l'ensemble de la
population dans les années à venir
oui
[Musique]